what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
um sorry for the lack of content lately
i've been traveling i just made it to la
and yeah i've just been doing stuff
but don't worry the content is back in
here to stay today
i am going to be reacting to
this looks like a mari type video but
it's like judge
mathis someone sent this to me on
instagram as you guys know do not forget
to like comment and subscribe
if you guys have any video requests for
me make sure you send them to me on
instagram that's the best way to reach
me i always like
look before i do these videos
okay i just want to make sure the sound
is working
okay plaintiff bob kreisel says when he
became friends with the defendant
others warned him to watch his back
because she's a drug user
and the defendant confessed that she'd
been arrested 17 times for heroin
bob is suing her today for a loan
okay this is interesting because
a lot of the red pill content talks
about how like men get taken advantage
of for their money
so i think this is point in case right
defendant diana hoyler says she started
using drugs when she was 20
and she was addicted to heroin for 31
years
diana admits that she borrowed money
from bob but claims
he asked her to repay him with oral sex
start with you uh i'm going to give you
a little bit about this gal she's a real
piece of work
when i first um when i first met her
when i met her at a bar it was back
around the end of january
2018 okay i really didn't know her
a whole lot but the other people around
the area they knew her
and they kind of said hey you don't want
to you don't want to get
dealt up with why with her because she
was like
they said all she does drugs she um
red flag she's a user
she borrows money she don't pay it back
but her and i got talking
and i didn't i thought that uh
well she was arrested for out of her
mouth
17 times for using
heroin and even jailed
and she's supposed to have 17 felonies
but anyways
when i had she stopped when you met her
it seemed to me that way
but the other people were saying
different but i thought she wanted to
get her life trained out
that's what she told me so what was it
like when you are how long did you date
first
it's interesting how on the outside
looking in things look like very obvious
red flags and like i've been in this
situation and i've also been on the
outside
of situations like this and
i don't know when you like
like when people are attracted to each
other or like even in just like a
friendship sort of way you kind of miss
all the red flags and maybe you're out
obvious on the outside looking at it we
didn't date oh okay
no no she was just a friend of mine and
they everybody knew we were just how'd
your friendship go do you saw each other
[Music]
it was good i mean you know she was
well you loaned a woman by your own
admission 650 dollars so yeah
you all did something you met at the bar
had a good time or you go no
bible study together i don't know what
you did
well no we did hang out and we went it
wasn't really dating
personally you're just asking the nature
of the friendship and would you say you
i i felt bad i felt bad for her i mean
she
she don't she was talking about she
wants to get her own apartment
she's tired of living with the drug
heads that she lives with man
it's funny empathy is the
strongest human emotion i swear
all the times i felt like i've been
taken advantage of it's because like
i've been very
empathetic and like kind to people
but my dad always told me that if you
lend someone money
to just not expect it back and if you
get it back like great but don't
expect to get it back and every time
i've lent money it's been money that
like i could lose like
you know i would want back and i'd be
annoyed if someone didn't give it to me
back
but that's kind of the mindset you have
to go
with lending money especially to friends
i chased about my background i was
married at 14 years old
i started using drugs experimenting with
them at the age of 20.
i became addicted to heroin i've been a
heroin addict for 31 years
i've been to prison five times
i've lost like nine good friends due to
heroin overdoses
last year i woke up with a good friend
of mine laying next to me
across me dead from a heroin overdose
i'm surprised she's still alive
and i mean this in the like she looks
pretty old so she was she used to be 50.
my cousin i had a cousin that like was
addicted to drugs and he died at 39 and
he was like the oldest of all of his
friends
and that kind of affected me and for the
first time
i asked for treatment
and i've been clean for 14 months now
how did you get started so young how
oh my gosh she was 15 when she started
and she's 50 now
like
the only incentive you have is to maybe
not die early
it's not even like life to look forward
to
you got with the wrong person and he's a
man too you
get no good men to get women hooked on
drugs we'll be doing fine meeting no
good man boom
and they getting high with him started
off on heroin stuck right there i mean
started at the top
in just 31 years 31 years now
what about your parents and all how did
that go with the relationship with your
family
they they've stood by me they did not
enable me at all
you didn't rip them off no no i went to
prison for burglary of habitation
ripping everybody's butt now
there you go yeah i'm going over here
that's right
hold your pockets
we're having fun with you because we're
happy that you're in recovery
14 months is a good stretch of recovery
and hopefully you're attending in a
which will continue that recovery
right i've given to a few i don't go to
them a lot why
i haven't needed them so far i mean this
is true yes you do you don't know you
need them
until you relapse true right well then
you need
yeah yeah but 31 years he did
your drug counselor tell you don't need
to go or you only need to go a few times
no
what does he say or he or she say stay
in
yeah right every day yeah just being
honest
i just don't know a lot and they have
them running from 6 00 a.m
to 6 a.m the next morning right yes you
can always find the n.a meeting
that's very important now let me get
further into your friendship with this
gentleman okay
we met we became pretty good friends i
thought and
we went out a few times he became gay we
would go drink we would go out to the to
eat we would
do different little things you know he'd
never been on you
no i know that yes you did yes you did
yes you did no i didn't you got a woman
no
you got a wife or a woman no sir you
were just slow rolling he was hitting on
you
he was just slow you don't have a wife
or a woman you were getting on this
woman
did i not stay the night with you uh oh
your dad stays at night
why because you got too drunk you
couldn't drive home
damn who got you yes he did stupid
almost had sex but somebody else was too
drunk and couldn't
so don't go there oh
don't go there oh you know you're lying
don't go there
okay to be fair
i feel like they're both probably actors
but assuming this is real
can you really trust like a drug i'm not
trying to be rude but like
a drug addict she's good at telling you
what you want to hear
which brings me to the rest of my let me
hear from you about it brings you
to the rest of my term that's what made
me think
that she was going to try to straighten
up and she went she needed
she talked about getting a job well she
did get a job
so she wanted to get this car she was
taking a cab with her tip money
to get to the job so i decided i
did mention to her that i could help her
get her a car i could give her a deposit
that boy once i said that that was it
you know hey can we go car shopping
tomorrow that's a day i said
why don't you see if we can keep the job
a little bit you know
well she wanted to get the car so
anyways we went to the car lot
and i and they wanted the 700 for the
deposit and i told her at that time
right there that
i'd lend it to her on my credit card
because i go if i give you cash
i'm going to have to have it back
quickly but if you do a credit card
you can make at least the minimum
payments
until it's paid off that is not wise to
get a car
right away well i gave her that
was that a certain agreement okay sir i
can't even you let money do a drug
addict what did you expect to happen
this is an agreement okay she signed it
and then um
well she made the first two payments but
they were late
i had to hunt her down for him because
at this point once you got the car
our friendship already started kind of
the window
let me hear from her ma'am the date
should be on there when i made the
payments
all right but tell me about the loan and
you did agree to repay it
yes sir all right and then so the
agreement was i would pay the minimum
balance
due on the credit card each month uh
after my second payment
he started saying that he wanted more
than the 25 dollars a month because he's
going
he just said pay more when you can he
said but you need to start paying more
than the 25 because
i said we're not going to be able to
continue this 25
after i signed that's true oh no
we talked about that her making more but
more than
who would do 25. but then that's what
you had that's what you had me saying
i did i wrote it you would do 25. i
wrote it you probably thought she was
about to get next to
her yeah so that's what you did you
thought you were getting next to her she
tricked you out that 25
that's not the case at all yeah he was
finessed
finessed what it was is i noticed that
after i even said
i wish i would have put the 100 at least
a minimum but i wrote the minimum
you know okay then the 25 she didn't
make those either
then she quit making them completely and
ma'am did this
discussion occur he said i need to start
paying more and i told him when i could
i would because i didn't want it to take
two years to pay off
and he also wouldn't bring it up the
first promissory note that he gave me
to sign
the bottom line it was that exactly but
the bottom line was and oral sex once a
week on demand
so i know
damn
well
okay i officially believe the girl
i officially believe her because he
admitted to making that joke if you made
that joke
sorry and what guy would do all this for
a friend
ah cursing mouth said oh that was a joke
believe me
all right so i didn't sign it and i
signed that one she's excited you would
prefer her sign that other one tell her
she did sign it
i should have kept it she signed the
other one the first one yes she did sign
it i did not and then i said no no no i
said whoever
no i don't even think she read it i
think she's assigned it and i said hey
read that
re you know because i did like that
and then when she looked at it i said no
no no because i already had
i already had that one too and i said no
here's the real one so if i were
to hit with the other one he wouldn't
have gave me this one man you'd have
been bound by the other contract
which i could not enforce that would be
an illegal contract oh boy
i would not have been able to enforce an
illegal contract
this contract is legal you do admit to
owing
and i'm going to grant him the balance
650
on that loan have a good day folks
why did they go through that whole thing
like all the personal details
really did not need to be shared
but it's all fake and for tv right okay
um if you guys like this type of content
let me know in the comments
don't forget to like comment and
subscribe i will talk to you guys next
time